SAAD ALI: Hello, everyone.
We're here at KubeCon
Barcelona with Dustin Kirkland.
Dustin is Product
Manager of GKE.
Dustin is going to be
telling us about Windows.
Windows in Google.
Why?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
It's something that we've heard
quite a bit from customers
lately.
Those of us around
the Linux ecosystem
have long been putting our
workloads, our applications
into Linux containers and
using Kubernetes to orchestrate
those containers.
Until recently, that's
really not been available
for Windows workloads.
And half of the
world's workloads
are still developed on
Windows and for Windows.
So with the release of
Windows Server 2019,
the Windows Server kernel has
built into it functionality
that operates very much
like Linux containers.
And so in the upstream
Kubernetes community,
Microsoft, Google, and a
number of other companies
have been instrumental in adding
support for Windows Server
containers to Kubernetes.
And as of Kubernetes 1.14, the
upstream open source release
of Kubernetes has declared
Windows container support
generally available.
SAAD ALI: Very cool.
So what kind of
features are going
to be available in this release?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah, so
you should really think
about your basic applications.
We're focused on,
largely, first-party apps,
the apps that either you have
the source code to and you
develop yourself
on top of Windows,
or apps that are being
developed, new .NET apps,
new Visual Basic, or C++,
we see a lot of in Windows.
So new apps that can be compiled
and built into a container
image we can deploy now directly
to GKE as a Windows application
on a Windows node.
And then, importantly, we
get this question a lot,
but yes, you can have
Windows nodes and Linux
nodes in the same cluster.
Those pods can communicate.
You can have applications,
a .NET application running
in a Windows Server container
that's talking to a MySQL
service running in
a Linux container.
SAAD ALI: That's very cool.
So you're going to have
Windows and Linux coexisting
in a single GKE cluster.
When can customers get
their hands on this?
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah,
so as of GKE 114,
the Rapid release channel, we'll
have the functionality built
into it.
We're making that available
in an early access program,
and we're onboarding
our first customers now.
We have a sign-up
link that we can
send you to to sign up
for that early access.
We'll run it through its
paces, first an early access,
then an alpha, then a
beta, and then a GA.
SAAD ALI: That's super exciting.
Well, we're looking
forward to that.
Thank you very much, Dustin
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]